اللي شايفينه قدامكم ده هو افي اس خرووف
الكاتب الرئيسي للمسلسل الاسرائيلي الشهير
فوضى اللي بيصور الصراع بشكل متحيز طبعا
بين وحده خاصه في جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وبين اصحاب الارض الفلسطينيين وواحد من
الاسرائيليين اللي مؤمنين بمزعم الاحتلال
الكذبه زي مثلا وجود مقرات لقياده
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تحت مستشفيات غزه وزي
ان كتائب عز الدين القسام بتستخدم مواطني
غزه كدروع بشريه وغيرها من الكلام الفارغ
ده المهم من شهوره اثناء اجتماع عصف ذهني
لكتابه احدى حلقات المسلسل بعد نجاحه
وانتشاره في مواسمه الاولى في حد في
الاجتماع اقترح فكره غريبه ومجنونه جدا
وقال ما تيجوا يا جماعه نكتب حلقه نصور
فيها عشرات من مقاتلي حماس وهم بيعملوا
عمليه غير مسبوقه بيقتح فيها الجدار
الحديد العازل بين قطاع غزه واسرائيل وبيح
جم مستوطنات الغلاف اللي حوالين القطاع
ساعتها افي قال يا اخوانا قولوا كلام يعقل
احتماليه ان عشرات فضلا عن الاف من مقاتلي
الحركه يقدروا ينفذوا هجوم بالحجم ده من
غير ما جهاز الاستخبارات الداخليه الشباك
والمخابرات العسكريه امان ياخدوا بالهم
فسيبك من الفكره اللي ما فيش حد هيصدق دي
وخلونا نشوف فكره واقعيه اكتر طبعا تتصور
ان افي ندم جدا على انه ساب الفكره دي تمر
من تحت ايده لانه يوم 7 اكتوبر اللي فات
يعني من 36 يوم بس اتحقق السيناريو
الجنوني ده بالحرف وبالفعل اطلقت كتائب عز
الدين القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه حماس هجومها الواسع
المعروف بطوفان الاقصى بمئات المقاتلين
على مستوطنات غلاف غزه واللي متابعينه
كلنا ومتابعين تداعياته من ساعتها واخت
رقه الجدار العازل كانها بتتمشى في
الحديقه الخلفيه لبيت عادي لكن الحقيقه ان
وجهه نظر افي دي او استبعاده التام لهجوم
زي ده كانت هي بالضبط وجهه نظر مجتمع
الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي كله المجتمع اللي
ميزانيته زادت في الش سنين اللي فاتوا
الضعف واللي بيتصرف عليه حاليا اكت من 5
مليار دولار سنويه واللي اجهزته الرئيسيه
لا تخضع الا لرئيس وزراء الكيان المحتل بس
واللي بيعتبر اقوى منظومه استخباراتيه في
الشرق الاوسط وتاني اقوى منظومه استخبارات
في الغرب واكثرها تطورا بعد مجتمع
الاستخبارات الامريكي اهو المجتمع ده كله
بقوته بميزانيتها المهوله فشل تماما في
التنبؤ بهجوم حماس وفي تجميع المعلومات
المتناثره علشان يقدر يتوقعه ولو قبلها
بفتره قصيره وكان فشله و ده من ضمن
الاسباب الرئيسيه اللي ادت لتحطيم اسطوره
منظومه الامن الاسرائيليه التي لا تقهر
ولو ركزنا هنلاقي ان المره الاخيره اللي
تعرض فيها ايمان الاسرائيليين الجماعي
بمتانته وقوه اجهزتهم الاستخباراتيه
للتدمير بالشكل العنيف ده كان من 50 سنه
في بدايه حرب اكتوبر
1973 الحرب اللي بيعتبرها بروس ريدل احد
كبار محللي شؤون الشرق الاوسط السابق في
وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه سي اي ايه
انها مثال كلاسيكي على كيفيه فشل
الاستخبارات لما فوجئ الاسرائيليين بهجوم
شامل شنته القوات المصريه والسوريه بعد
خطه خداع ما زالت بتدرس في الكليات
العسكريه العالميه لحد اللحظه فكان واضح
ان حماس نجحت جدا في تكرار فيلم الرعب ده
وبامكانيات ابسط بمراحل مقارنه بالعدو
وواضح ان المسؤولين الاسرائيليين ارتكبوا
نفس الاخطاء اللي ارتكبوها في حرب اكتوبر
والاخطاء دي قادته م لحرب طويله مش باين
لها افق لحد اللحظه ومكلفه جدا ودول
نقطتين الكيان المحتل مش بيحبهم ابدا لا
بيحب يخو حروب طويله ولا بيحب يخسر فلوس
في حلقه النهارده المهمه جدا هنرجع مع بعض
لورا كم اسبوع بس علشان نحاول نفهم ايه
اللي حصل بالظبط لاجهزه استخبارات
الاحتلال يعني ازاي المقاومه خدعتها
بالشكل ده والمليارات اللي بتتصرف عليها
دي كلها بتروح فين وهل الفشل ده بيساهم
فعلا في زياده خساير الاحتلال الاقتصاديه
من الحرب ده جزء من اللي هندردش فيه
النهارده بس بفكركم قبلها ان منصات ومواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي عامله قيود كبيره على
انتشار المحتوى المضاد للكيان المحتل
فهمتكم معانا باللايك والتفاعل مع الفيديو
علشان يظهر للناس انا اشرف ابراهيم ده
المخبل
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي قبل ما نبدا ده انا وفريق
المخبر الاقتصادي هنكون حابين نشكر جدا
شركه تلا فيت راعي حلقتنا النهارده شركه
تلا فيت اتاسس سنه 2017 وهي شركه فيتناميه
اسسها شاب مصري مكافح اسمه ضياء الدين
امين وبتصدر لاسواق مصر والسعوديه والاردن
وتركيا وغيرها منتجات مختلفه زي البن
والفلفل وجوز الهند والقرفه والكاجو
هتلاقوا تحت الفيديو بيانات شركه تلا فيت
لو في شركه او تاجر حابب يتعامل معاهم
ويستورد من خلالهم والمنتجات دي يا ريت
تعملوا ده في اول 2018 وقف نداف ارجمان
مدير الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه الداخليه
المعروفه بالشباك او الشن بيت وقتها في
جلسه سريه قدام لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
والدفاع علشان يعرض عليهم تقرير انجازات
الجهاز في 2017 والمخاطر المستقبليه
للسنين الجايه في الجلسه دي واللي اتسرب
جزء منها لبعض وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
شرح نداف لاعضاء الكنيست انه في خلال 2017
كشف الشباك ما لا يقل عن 148 خليه تابعه
لحركه حماس كانت بتستعد العمليات في الضفه
الغربيه وان استجواب اعضاء الخلايا وضح
للاسرائيليين وجود ثمان خطط مفصله لاختطاف
جنو مدنيين وان الوضع مش مستقر بالمره لا
في غزه ولا في الضفه الغربيه ومؤسسه
الدفاع بتاعتنا بتواجه تحديات كبيره وقال
لهم بالحرف ان الوضع الحالي هو الهدوء
الذي يصب العاصفه وقتها مجتمع استخبارات
الاحتلال كان عنده هاجس واحد بس هو اللي
شغله وهو انه في وقت قريب واحده من مئات
المحاولات اللي المقاومه بتخطط لها سنويا
هيتم تجاهلها او تفوتها في نهايه المطاف
وبالتالي تنفذها وانه لو حصل هجوم ضخم
واحد فده هيغير الوضع السياسي في المنطقه
كلها في نفس الوقت ده كانت وحده ابحاث
الشباك الداخليه وصلت لحاله مذريه من
الضعف والتهميش
الوحده دي يا اخوانا تم انشائها مع بدايه
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الاولى سنه
1987 لما الكيان المحتل لقى ان مجتمع
الاستخبارات كله ما فيش فيه قسم يقدر
يتابع تطور التهديدات اللي بتواجهه ويقدم
تحذيرات مسبقه بخصوصها فانشق الوحده دي
جوه الشباك لكن مع السنين تهمش تماما تلف
الايام ويتغير نداف ارجمان ويمسك مكان
رونين بار اللي الظاهر انه ما كانش عاوز
يزعل رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو او يضايقه بتقارير ممكن يشوفها
مبالغ فيها طب ليه مش عاوز يزعل نتنياهو
لان نتنياهو هو اكث رئيس وزراء في تاريخ
الكيان المحتل زود الانفاق الدفاعي
وميزانيه اجهزه الاستخبارات اللي فشلت فشل
ذريع في التعامل مع استعدادات المقاومه
الذكيه وهو نفسه خدم في وحده نخبه
الكوماندو سيره ماتكال اللي جزء معتبر من
مهامها استخباراتيه وحاولت تتجسس على
منظومه اتصالات حركه حماس في 2018 وفشلت
في ده فشل ذريع في عمليه شهيره في السياق
ده بقى مهم نعرف شويه معلومات سريعه عن
تاريخ زيادات ميزانيه مجتمع الاستخبارات
الاسرائيلي على ايد نتانياهو وتحديدا جهاز
الاستخبارات الداخليه الشباك والخارجيه
الموساد لو بصينا هنلاقي ان ارقام
الميزانيه دي زادت بشكل كبير من ساعه ما
تولى رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو منصبه
سنه 2009 ووصلت في 2018 ل 2.4 مليار دولار
وده رقم لا يشمل ميزانيه جهاز الاستخبارات
العسكري ولا يشمل تكلفه معاشات التقاعد
للموظفين اللي تقاعدوا من وكالتين واللي
بتوصل لحوالي 259 مليون دولار سنويه على
مر السنين الحكومات الاسرائيليه اخفت
ميزانيات المساد والشباك عن الاسرائيليين
وفي 2014 كشفت صحيفه هارتس الاسرائيليه ان
الحكومه كانت بتحول الاموال بشكل شكل سري
للجهازين وده كان معناه انه ما فيش رقابه
على الفلوس دي ولا بتروح فين في 2015 ومع
انتخابات الحكومه وافق ياير لابيد وزير
ماليه الاحتلال في الوقت ده ودان هارل
المدير العام لوزاره الدفاع على فصل تمويل
الشباك والموساد عن ميزانيه جيش الاحتلال
وحطوها بشكل مستقل تحت بند اسمه الرمز 31
وفي بدايه 2018 تم ادراج الموازنه دي ضمن
بند موازنه الاحتياط العام مع تقديم طلب
بعد كده للجنه الماليه في الكنيست
لتحويلها للموساد والشباك التوجهات
الامنيه دي دايما كانت هي المفضله لرئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو زي ما قلنا اللي واحده من
جمله هي انه في حاجه اسرائيليه مستمره
لزياده الانفاق الدفاعي لضمان المزيد من
النمو الاقتصادي وفي خطاب ليه في نهايه
2018 قال ان النفقات الامنيه الاضافيه
هتروح لتعزيز القدرات الهجوميه للبلاد
والقدرات السيبرانيه وتحديث انظمتها
الدفاعيه المضاده للصواريخ وتدابير
الحمايه على الجبهه الداخليه واستكمال
الحواجز الامنيه الكلام ده انعكس بشكل
واضح على استراتيجيه نتنياهو في التعامل
مع قطاع غزه وحركه حماس اللي بتحكمه وهي
كانت استراتيجيه بسيطه ومباشره احنا
هنحاسب من كل ناحيه وهنعمل مشاريع امنيه
حواليه تخليه اكبر سجن مفتوح ومراقب في
العالم وهنرفع حل الدولتين وهنستخدم لوجود
حماس لاضعاف السلطه الفلسطينيه مع شن
عمليات كل كام سنه لتدمير قدرات المقاومه
وارجاعها لنقطه الصفر علشان تنشغل في
بنائها من جديد علشان كده هنلاقي
الاسرائيليين طلعوا بكل المشروعات
المجنونه اللي حصروا بها القطاع زي
استكمال الحاجز البحري اللي بيفصل القطاع
عن الحدود البحريه للكيان المحتل والجدار
الحديد المسلح اللي بلغ طوله اكثر من 40
ميل فوق وتحت الارض وزي نظام مراقبه
الحدود اللي بيعتمد بشكل شبه حصري على
الكاميرات واجهزه الاستشعار والمدافع
الرشاشه اللي بيتم تشغيلها عن بعد فكل ده
مع التكنولوجيا الفائقه اللي بتتمتع بها
اجهزه الاستخبارات زي شبكه كاميرات ستار
تراك لمراقبه الحدود واللي بتستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي للتعرف على الاشخاص والاشياء
بشكل دقيق جدا والداتا المهوله اللي
بياخدوها من الاقمار الصناعيه بتاعتهم او
الامريكيه كمان ضمن برامج تباد للمعلومات
بينهم وبين الامريكيين والطائرات بدون
طيار اللي بتحلق في سماء غزه 24 ساعه
وغيرها وغيرها من التقنيات المتطوره جدا
كل ده خلى المسؤولين العسكريين
الاسرائيليين يؤمنوا تماما انه من
المستحيل تقريبا على اي حد انه يتسلل
لاسرائيل وفي نفس الوقت خلى القله العاقله
منهم واللي كانت عارفه ان الاسلوب ده لا
يمكن انه يسيطر على اسود المقاومه خلاهم
يخافوا من مواجهه نتنياهو مجلس الوزراء
بمخاوفهم دي وتقييماتهم خوفا على مناصبهم
بجانب ده في اجهزه الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه ما اخدتش بالها من كذا علامه
تحذير طلعوا في وشها او تعاملت مع بعض
العلامات دي باستخفاف وكان في افتقاد
للخيال فيما يخص اللي تقدر عليه حماس
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه عموما يعني مثلا
سلاح الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي التابع لقوات
الاحتلال البريه اي سي سي سي واللي بيجمع
الاستخبارات ليها من على الارض وتح ديدا
الوحده
414 المعروفه بوحده نصر والمسؤول عن
مراقبه النشاطات على حدود قطاع غزه كانت
رصدت تدريبات لبعض قوات حماس على تفجير
حاجز او سور وهمي مرارا وتكرارا ودي
تدريبات كلنا شفنا جزء منها لما نشرتها
كتائب عز الدين القسام بعد طوفان 7 اكتوبر
على صعيد اخر هنلاقي ان الوحده 8200 اللي
هي فخر الوحدات الاستخباراتيه التقنيه في
الكيان المحتل وقبل عمليه 7 اكتوبر بسنه
كامله توقفت تماما عن التنس على اجهزه
اللا سلك المحموله اللي استخدمها مقاتله
حماس في التواصل ليه ده حصل لان الوحده
تصورت ان ده تضييع للموارد والجهد على
الناحيه الثانيه هنلاقي ان حماس عرفت
تستغل كل ثغره موجوده في انظمه
الاستخبارات والدفاع الاسرائيليه اللي
بيتصرف عليها عشرات المليارات واللي هيخلي
الاسرائيليين يفضلوا سنين طويله يدرسوا
اللي حصل ده ولقت ان افضل وسيله لمواجهه
العدو بالغ التطور ده هو الرجوع للعصر
الحجري بدايه من استخدام تليفونات ارضيه
او وسائل اتصال ثنائيه لا يمكن التنس
عليها بسهوله الهواتف المحموله وليس
انتهاء بدس معلومات مغلوطه للاسرائيليين
في كل مكان يعني بدايه كده هنلاقي ان حركه
حماس انشات وطورت جهاز استخبارات خاص بها
نجح تماما وفقا لدراسه في مجله
الاستخبارات والامن الوطني صدرت في مايو
اللي فات 2023 20 نجح في مراقبه الحدود مع
اسرائيل وتشغيل عملاء لحساب المقاومه في
كل انحاء الاراضي المحتله ونجح في انه
يستمع لبعض اهم الاتصالات التكتيكيه لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه والاهم انها مررت
معلومات مضلله من خلال القنوات اللي كانت
عارفه ان المخابرات الاسرائيليه بترابها
بياكد على ده الون ارفس العضو السابق في
الوحده 8200 اللي قال انه من الواضح ان
حماس تمكنت من تجاوز قدره اس يل على
اعتراض الاتصالات الهاتفيه والبريد
الالكتروني وتعلمت كيفيه جمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه الاسرائيليه وكيفيه تجنب
كشف المعلومات الخاصه بها الشيء الاهم
واللي سلطت عليه الضوء بث سانر نائبه مدير
الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكي السابق هو
ان حماس اتبعت اقدم مدرسه ممكنه في
التخطيط والتواصل وما كانش في اي تواصل
الكتروني يخلي الاسرائيليين يقدروا يكشفوا
الملامح العامه للخط بل بالعكس بتعتقد ان
حماس قسموا افراد العمليه لمجموعات صغيره
كل مجموعه ما تعرفش غير مهمتها بس
والاجتماعات بينهم بتكون فرديه بينما اللي
عارف الخطه كلها عدد لا يتجاوز اصابع اليد
الواحده وبالشكل ده ما حدش في المجموعات
دي كان مستوعب حجم الهجمات اللي كانوا
بيتدربوا عليها وما كانوش يقدروا يكشفوا
الخطه لو تم القبض على حد فيهم مثلا او
بعضهم وحتى لما كانت حماس بتستعد للعمليه
فضلت على اصال يومي مع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه علشان التنسيق المتواصل لحصص
تصدير بعض البضايع وتصاريح العمال اللي
بيطلعوا من غزه للاراضي المحتله وده خلى
عدد كبير من المسؤولين الاسرائيليين يجزم
بان العمال دول ساعدوا في جمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه الحساسه بما في ذلك الخرايط
الدقيقه لمستوطنات الغلاف وما تحتوي عليه
مع بدايه يوم 7 اكتوبر بقى وفي منتصف
الليل كان عدد من ضباط الشباك محللي
المعلومات هناك وعلى راسهم مدير الشباك
روند بار نفسه ولما شاف اللي بيحصل ما
كانش عارف لا هو ولا غيره يجزم باي حاجه
يعني هل دي انشطه غريبه للمقاومه ولا ده
تدريب ليلي عادي من تدريبات حماسه
المعتاده وبمرور الوقت اعتقد رونين ان
حماس اخرها في الحياه محاوله شن هجوم على
نطاق صغير وبعد ما ناقش تخوفه ده مع كبار
الجنرالات الاسرائيليين امر مدير شن بيت
فريق تكيله الانتشار على الحدود الجنوبيه
للكيان المحتل وتكيلا هي وحده النخبه
السريه التابعه للجهاز واللي بيتبس لها في
اسرائيل على انها الملاز الاخير في وقف اي
هجوم وشيك وبعد ساعات قليله وحده تكيله
لقت نفسها وجها لوجه مع مقاتلي كتائب عز
الدين القسام اللي لقوهم داخلين عليهم زي
العاصفه من كل مكان في البر والبحر والجو
طبعا الفشل الاسرائيلي الاستخبارات المذري
ده مش من نصيب الشباك بس وانما كمان من
نصيب الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه ام
اي اللي
بتتولد هي عن مراقبه التطورات في غزه
واللي حكايتها حكايه في الاستهانه التامه
بقدرات المقاومه يعني لو بصينا هنلاقي انه
من مايو 2021 كان التقييم الرسمي
للمخابرات العسكريه الاسرائيليه ومجلس
الامن القومي هو ان حماس مالهاش اي مصلحه
في شن هجوم من غزه على الاراضي المحتله في
الوقت الحالي وان مهتمه بس بحكم القطاع
وكان تقديرهم ان حماس بتحاول تعمل عمليات
ضد الاسرائيليين في الضفه الغربيه بس
واعتقدوا بشكل واضح جدا انهم عرفوا يديروا
تحدي السيطره على حركه حماس بنجاح علشان
كده المدير الحالي لمخابرات الاحتلال
العسكريه ارون حليفا وقف في مايو اللي فات
2023 في مؤتمر هيرتس ليا الانوي اهم مؤتمر
امني وعسكري في اسرائيل واللي بيحضر معظم
قيادات الاحتلال من كل المستويات وقال
للحضور ان حركه حماس مهتمه بالحفاظ على
الهدوء في القطاع في السنتين اللي فاتوا
ولحد اللحظه وان حماس حاليا مش شايفه ان
الانخراط في القتال مع اسرائيل او
الاشتباك معاها عن طريق اطلاق صواريخها
على الجنوب حفيدها باي شكل من المفارقات
الساخره واللي نبهنا ليها بروفيسور العلوم
السياسيه الاسرائيلي الشهير يوري بار
جوزيف هو ان مخابرات الاحتلال العسكريه
ارتكبت نفس الخطا اللي ارتكبته في حرب
اكتوبر بالملي لما تجاهلت معلومات واضحه
قبل الحرب مباشره عن انشطه مصريه على
الضفه وجزمت بان دي تدريبات عاديه وبعد 50
سنه كرروا نفس الغلطه لما بلغتهم يعير
روتنبرغ جنديه الرصد الاسرائيليه على حدود
غزه عن بعض انشطه رجال المقاومه قبل
الهجوم وردوا عليها بان دي انشطه زراعيه
غالبا ومافيش فيها خطر بعد حرب اكتوبر
طورت الاستخبارات العسكريه نسخه اسرائيليه
من تكنيك تحليلي بيطلق عليه اسم محامي
الشيطان ودي وحده كانت مهمتها تقديم
سيناريو معاكس للسيناريوهات التقليديه او
المتوقعه او المتفق عليها يعني لو جهاز
الاستخبارات العسكريه كله متفق على ان
حماس مش ممكن تعمل حاجه فمهم الوحده دي
انها تفترض حدوث هجوم حمساوي باكبر صوره
ممكنه لكن يبدو زي ما بيقول بروفيسور يوري
ان سيناريو افتراض هجوم طوفان الاق
ما كانش موجود في المخيله الاسرائيليه
بالمره وما فكروش في الاستفادات اللي
هتحقق المقاومه من اطلاق شن عمليه عسكريه
وسعه النطاق عمليه يمكن ليها انها تحط
المنظمه على الخريطه وتقوض بشكل اساسي
شعور اسرائيل بالامن وصورتها كقوى اقليميه
ده غير الاعتقاد الجماعي الاسرائيلي بان
حماس مش ممكن تقدر تنفذ عمليه واسعه بدون
علم الشباك والمخابرات العسكريه هو قاط
حماس دمرته على ما يبدو للابد الفشل
الاستخباراتي ده كلف الكيان المحتل دخول
حرب هو غير مستعد لها على الاطلاق بشهاده
حلفاؤه نفسهم وده ادى لخسائر اقتصاديه
مهوله بتتزاك لحظه وربما تفضي بالكيان
المحتل لكارثه اقتصاديه يعني يكفي تعرفوا
ان الحرب الحاليه بتكلف الاحتلال 260
مليون دولار يوميا وان خسائره من بدايه
العدوان على غزه تجاوزه ال 8 مليار دولار
بينما بتتوقع وزاره الماليه الاسرائيليه
ان الخسائر دي هتعدي 50 مليار دولار على
الاقل لو الحرب كملت لشهور قادمه ولحد سنه
مثلا والرقم الضخم جدا ده بافتراض ان
الحرب هتفضل مكمله على قطاع غزه بس بدون
ما تتفتح اي جبهات ثانيه سواء في لبنان او
ايران وبفرض برضو عوده عدد كبير من
احتياطي جيش الاحتلال الموجودين حاليا على
ذمه الجيش ل اعمالهم الطبيعيه لحد هنا انا
خلصت كلامي وقبل ما اختم عندي سؤال
لحضراتكم اسرائيل بتحاول تعمل غزو بر شامل
لقطاع غزه زي ما انتم عارفين والامريكان
بيحذرو ه من الخطوه دي تفتكروا ايه اللي
منتظر الجنود الاسرائيليين لو دخلوا في
عمق القطاع اتابع كل اجاباتكم في
التعليقات هتلاقوا تحت الفيديو بيانات
شركه تلا فيت لو في شركه او تاجر حابب
يتعامل معاهم ويستورد من خلالهم المنتجات
دي يا ريت تعملوا ده وفي النهايه نتمنى
السلامه لاهلنا واخواتنا في قطاع غزه وفي
كامل الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله احنا
معاكم وجنبكم بفكركم بالتفاعل مع الفيديو
علشان يظهر للناس ويفلت من القيود الحاليه
لمنصات التواصل الاجتماعي كلها على اي
محتوى مناهض للكان المحتل
[موسيقى]
سلام